I know losing your speed is scary.
Don't let him get to you. Too late!
I'll use a booster Speed steroids?
We have no idea what he could do to you
You're gonna be too weak to stop me.
Then, the fun's really gonna begin somehow
Somehow, he's taken over Nash's body.
Hi flash.
Thawne
What do you want?
What do I always want?
To kill you.
And I'm done being patient.
I can't wait to slit your throat.
And when I do
When I get out.
Believe me
I will get out
I'm going to kill you
Then I'm going to kill your family.
Then, I'm going to kill your friends.
I'm going to kill all your friends.
starting
with your new pal Nash
no
no?
Whatever you've done to him. We're
gonna stop you.
But isn't it true...
In a few short weeks.
You're going to be powerless
to stop me.
Right?
Because your Speed Force is dead.
I can feel it. That's what
you get Barry. For trusting such a
puny pathetic force that's why I built
my own.
I'm coming.
I'm coming for you
We're done here.
Tick Tock
Spectre energy.
Okay yeah well
that's just energy we don't understand
yet but that's something we can figure
out right absolutely we can run some
tests figure out how to track it thanks
guys, but I...
I want your help with something else.
I've been thinking about what Thawne said
you mean how he's gonna kill us all yeah
me too
how he built his own power source the
negative Speed Force.
If he can make one, then
So can we.
I need your help to build an
artificial speed force.
That's how I can get my speed back.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this is going to be my flash
season 6 episode 15 trailer video
reverse flash vs flash as he tries to
create his reverse negative speed force
make as many flash puns as you can think
of if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing a flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your best theory about what's
going to happen with reverse flash after
they're done within this season I'll
address that at the end of the video
there are some other speedsters that are
coming around later to this season I
know you all have questions about what's
going on with God's speed in the Red
Death character from the comics that
they teased during season 5
don't worry I'll cover that stuff too
but we saw reverse flash come back as an
apparition who seemingly took over
Nashville's mind so somehow during
crisis on Infinite Earths when Nash
wells became the pariah character he
became psychically linked to all the
other wells from the multiverse in when
Oliver Queen as the spectre rebooted the
universe somehow all the other alternate
multiverse versions of wells got
connected to Nashville's mind we as the
audience know that the multiverse exists
the characters themselves do not know
that it exists Cisco claims that the
laws of physics have changed in this new
earth prime reality so a lot of that
will play out over the course of the
rest of the season in the episodes
hopefully they'll resolve that by the
finale I don't want them going into next
season not knowing about the multiverse
so that's how reverse flash got
connected to Nash wells and he's smart
enough to know how to take over his
consciousness so that he can control his
body he's back in the reverse-flash
costume because Barry keeps it inside
the Time Vault that's right he keeps
reverse flashes costume in deep storage
they also have a lot of other
reverse-flash technology from the early
seasons stored in a special locker where
they keep their big stuff I also wonder
if they put his time ship back in there
the last we saw that was at the end of
season 5 they seemingly broke it but I'm
sure that they would put all that back
in deep storage so that nobody would
investigate the pieces and try to find
out why someone had a time machine in
the first place their confrontation
inside the pipeline here though is
crazy this is the most vicious I've ever
seen the reverse-flash beat Tom Cavanagh
performing as reverse-flash is just
laying it on so thick I love how he
eases into it too like he's super casual
like hey how's it going how you guys
doing yeah I'm reverse-flash I'm just
hanging out in the pipeline and then
just proceeds to tell Barry he's going
to kill everyone that he loves then I'm
going to kill you all the worst nightmares
that Barry could ever have he just spits
out of his mouth I'm going to do all the
most terrible things that you could
think of as fun as it is to watch that
all happen here's the thing why are they
laying it on so thick why is the
reverse-flash being so overt in his
declaration to Barry I think part of the
reason why he's coming on so hard and
strong is because the character isn't
going to be around for more than a
little bit the back half of the season
and we probably won't see him for a
while hopefully they don't completely
fridge the character so then you see
them inside the speed lab here he needs
reverse flashes helped technically to
actually be able to reverse engineer the
negative Speed Force and create their
own artificial speed force more reverse
slash puns reverse engineer the negative
Speed Force you have to remember that
Thawne is a crazy genius from the
distant future and in that future he's
also considered a genius amongst his
other peers in the population so even
the simpletons in the future are way way
smarter than the smart people in present
day they're really hyping this up like
Barry taking speed steroids to get
faster which is the velocity ex
obviously they referenced in last week's
episode and earlier this season which
kind of makes it sound like an
after-school special like the Saved by
the Bell episode of the flash Barry did
the Yoda voice last week so bringing
that joke back around master Yoda would
say that the quick and easy way is the
path to the dark side so of course this
is going to go completely off the rails
reverse-flash spends more time taunting
Barry and when he's talking about the
Speed Force running out his speed powers
running out they keep zooming in on that
special green watch that Barry's wearing
while he starts crying a little bit
they might have just created that to
measure exactly how much speed forces
left because the Speed Force looks all
green with energy now I know a lot of
you are like hey wait a minute doesn't
inertia from the comics the evil clone
of bart allen have green speed force
lightning what's going on with that
there are other evil speedsters coming
around later this season but I don't
think that inertia
is going to be one of them but there was
a bit of a reference to the Mark Waid
era in the inertia character because
Mark Waid did the Bart Allen character
in inertia came for Bart Allen he was
the reverse-flash of the Bart Allen era
the whole thing with that Easter Egg was
when Wally West was talking about seeing
alternate futures with future
generations of speedsters Markway did a
cobalt blue story where you go into the
future centuries and there are many
different generations of speedsters as
part of the cobalt blue family future
cobalt blues and future flash speedsters
but the thing about cobalt blue is that
he was kind of like this twin of Barry
Allen and they haven't done that on the
TV show
people always ask are they ever going to do
cobalt blue people wanted Eddie to be
cobalt blue back in season 1 the only
other big speedsters that I know that
they're doing this season are God speed
just because in episode 18 God speed was
back filming in the episode but it's a
different actor I think it's all part of
the new rebooted Earth prime timeline
they can fix a lot of the stuff that
they did with God speed during season 5
that nobody really liked was not a big
fan of them burning such a big comic
book character the way that they did
during season 5 but I'm hoping that they
do is they develop the August heart
character and if they want to get rid of
reverse flash they could just have
autist heart God speed replace reverse
flash is the sort of main antagonist
speedster against Barry Allen for the
final seasons of the show they already
said that they know what next year's
crossover is going to be or technically
it's going to happen at the end of this
year remember Superman is going to have his
own TV show this year so Superman will
probably be much more of a main
character because arrow is gone
so whereas Oliver used to be one of the
main characters are crossovers Superman
is sort of taking that spot what I'm
hoping is is they do some Green Lantern
because they tease Green Lantern during
the ending of this year's crisis on
Infinite Earths part 5 then they have
the arrow finale scene with Diggle
getting the Green Lantern ring which
they haven't fully paid off yet but I'll
do more videos about that stuff and next
year's crossover when they reveal some
more details everyone post all your
theories about what's going to happen with
reverse flash after this next episode
there's been a bunch of news about
movies being delayed and TV shows
shutting down temporarily because of
what's going on and all the chaos I'll
try to do a new video tomorrow there's
some really good
spider-man news good news for a change
so look out for that video as long as
you have alerts enable for my channel
you'll see that video when I post it
congratulations football galaxy you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
flash video please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
details
everyone click here for that brand new
Marvel teaser for Falcon and Winter
Soldier and click here for that new boys
season 2 trailer video thank you so much
for watching everyone stay awesome we'll
see you guys tonight!